um
how did you guys job as a player and
coach what did you think the
um
how do you think of the job he did
yeah you know i think it's some it's
unfortunate to be honest because i've
never and i was saying this i never had
an issue with any of my coaches before
as much as people may assume or i've
never had an issue with any coach any
players any
staff members
anybody actually and we're keeping it
honest
and
from the moment i got here and you guys
don't notice but
i like uh it was actually frank's in his
wife's anniversary and i actually sent
him a bottle of champagne and stuff to
his hotel room which he know anything
about because i was
it's a nice thing to do nice gesture i'm
welcome coming to the team
congratulations to you guys and that's
the type of person i am i don't do it
for
anything back in return but that's just
something that i felt was right thing to
do and
i'm not sure
what his issue was with me or i'm not
sure why but
um i can't really give you an answer why
things we never really connected maybe
you know um that's something that he has
to answer but i never
you know from the get-go was feeling
like i was having to like try to
prove myself to him and my capabilities
and what i've been able to do for this
game and it's unfortunate but it's
really not i come out of my hands